si la france vient d'entrer dans son
troisième confinement et que les
citoyens ont été priés de devoir rester
chez eux le plus possible pour certains
la problématique est toute autre
rafle ils ont l'impression d'être
invisible dans la rue leur confinement
est un casse-tête au concert donné en
effet les sans-abri contraint à vivre
dans la rue et dépourvu de toute
protection sanitaire comme les masques
le gel hydroalcoolique se retrouve les
plus exposés au corona virus ça veut
dire qu'ils ont fait rossi est ce qu'ils
sont bien informés
c'est le cas d'alex qui depuis ses 15
ans vit dehors avec son chien qui a été
verbalisé par les forces de l'ordre
cette fois pour mon port du masque une
facture qui s'élève aujourd'hui à 645
euros et qu'il ne peut pas honorer
certaines personnalités comme remy
gaillard ont apporté leur soutien au
jeune homme
la justice l'a tout de même convoqué le
9 avril devant les tribunaux aujourd'hui
alex et sur notre plateau pour dénoncer
la situation des sans abri face à la
pandémie
nos différentes verbalisation dont ils
sont victimes merci alex d'être là 19
ans verbaliser cette fois pour non port
du masque avant qu'on vienne sur cette
histoire avec je te vois il est à 19 ans
tu étais sans domicile fixe qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dis moi parce que j'ai
on a envie de td on a envie de caisse
qui commence à affecter son domicile
fixe a fait combien de temps ben ça fait
depuis le 5 novembre 2020 que je suis
sans domicile fixe qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en fait tu faisais quoi
avant je t'ai j'habite à orange j'ai
alors un studio de 29 mètres carrés
comme les personnes lambda j'étais en
formation et l'information de quoi tu
devais pas c'est un dispositif qui
s'appelle la garantie jeunes avec la
mission locale
à quoi ces nous permet de trouver des
formations ou d'entrer dans un
apprentissage ou de faire des stages et
j'ai rencontré des amis je leur ai fait
confiance et c'est à dire que tu disais
baer juge les héberger chez moi d'accord
qui étaient en location
non j'étais en appartement thérapeutique
d'accord avec un chrs way et donc que tu
dois te dire ces personnes que tu quoi
tu t'es fait les potes en fait tout ça
c'est ça je me suis fait des amis et
j'ai hébergé ses amis sauf qu'ils ont
voulu squatter chez moi ils ont voulu
ouvrir dans un squat chez moi
concrètement et j'ai déjà appelé la
police pour les faire sortir de chez moi
et je retrouvais je suis partie d'orange
et j'ai retrouvé mon appartement saccagé
détruit les murs détruits le frigo
enlevée les meubles enlever tout enlevé
parce que ces personnes ont eu
on était énervé contre moi d'avoir avec
la police pour les faire sortir
c'est un coin est donc là ton domicile
que tu avais tu peux plus retourner
non j'ai fait l'état des lieux j'ai
rendu mon domicile je ne fais plus
partie le jeu chrs il a donc la tourne
toi tu es parti avant on était parti sur
montpellier ensuite le 5 novembre -
chaumont polis parce qu en fait j'étais
déjà la rue heures en 2020 sur en 2019
sur montpellier je restais à peu près
deux mois et ça s'était plutôt assez
bien passé pour moi
d'accord mais si un quoi parce qu'on le
voit et étaient tout jeunes atteints à
19 ans il voir à la rue moi ça me ça me
fend le coeur tu as de la famille tata
ou pas du tout
si j'ai ma mère qui est encore présente
à mes coéquipiers présente à mes côtés
elle sait que tu es sans domicile fixe
et bien sûr bien sûr elle sait que je
suis sans domicile fixe jeu lui-même je
lui il ya une dizaine de minutes avant
de venir sur le plateau et est allé
habitacle invite ma mère me pardonnez
moi ma mère habite à orange d'accord
avec ma belle mère et mes quatre soeurs
et mon père j'ai plus du tout de contact
avec et je n'en veux pas et point de vue
grands-parents et cousins cousines du
côté de ma mère je suis encore en
contact avec eux mais du côté de mon
père je suis plus en contact et jeu
complètement renié la famille de du côté
de mon père qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi tu en fait le neuf le 9
septembre 2015 j'ai fait une tentative
de suicide et j'étais hospitalisée à
l'hôpital psychiatrique de montpellier à
lapeyronie
c'est pourquoi tf1 dans des tenues de
suicides qu'est ce qui se passait parce
qu'en fait je quand je vivais chez lui
avec 15 ans ah oui j'avais 15 ans j'ai
l'ordre de mettre du divorce de mes deux
parents
j'ai choisi de partir vivre avec mon
père ce qui est encore là tout grosse
erreur de pasteur ci est mon père
m'interdisais d'appeler ma mère
m'interdise et d'appeler mes soeurs et
surtout maternisé d'appeler ma grand
mère maternelle et je lui en ai parlé
que c'était très important pour moi
d'appeler ma mère d'appeler ma famille
normale côté mme marois tout simplement
et il n'a pas voulu l'entendre et on
était en cours de technologie au collège
à marsillargues et j'ai pris un compas
j'ai voulu me scarifié le professeur est
arrivé au bon moment et m'a ramenée au
bureau du cpe et de là les pompiers sont
arrivés
je me suis fait hospitaliser comme j'ai
pu le lire à lapeyronie et suite à mon
hospitalisation mais mon père n'a pas
voulu me récupérer et ma mère ne pouvait
pas de me récupérer parce que l'était
déjà avec mes quatre soeurs et elles
étaient sans emploi
du coup c'est un peu compliqué pour elle
et je me suis retrouvé placé en foyer à
the avec 2 longueurs montpellier est là
aujourd'hui c'est quoi ton quotidien
était peut-être qu'ils identifient to
you ben aujourd'hui je suis dans un
foyer à un foyer pour sdf pour sans
domicile fixe à montpellier je vis je
vis je vivais pour l'instant de la
manche puisque j'ai pu j'ai pu effectuer
quelques missions d'un teckel que
quelques missions d'intérêt général
quelques missions d'intérim à dakar en
intérim et en tant que dans le domaine
de l'espace vert d'accord et ça ça n'a
pas du tout moment hélas aujourd'hui
j'ai aucune normalement je devais
commencer une mission aujourd'hui pour
le bâtiment
on y voit que peintre face à jay et j'ai
pas mon sujet pas reçu l'appel de ma
boîte d'intérim
parce que enfin j'ai aussi un appel de
ma boîte d'intérim qui magic ont là et
qu'ils n'avaient pas eu le retour du
client belgique ou la mission d'intérim
c'est annulé j'ai pas pu travailler
aujourd'hui et le manque de pot pour moi
c'était une mission quand même de deux
semaines qui pouvaient durer jusqu'à
trois quatre mois aujourd'hui c'est quoi
cette envie de dire quoi j'ai envie
d'avoir une vie lambda comme tout le
monde dans mon garde normalement ce que
tu as dix neuf ans thé voilà mon regard
je m'entende on
voilà qui pourrait être un pote à nous
c'est à dire que pour être notre fils
notre frère on le voit comme ça ça ça
nous ça nous touche énormément je suis
sûr que les téléspectateurs aussi au
départ n'était pas venu pour ça
j'étais venu vraiment pour parler du
port du masque et quand je t'ai vu
arriver je me suis dit comment ce
fait-il que ce garçon de 19 ans soit
sans domicile fixe je te sens vraiment
ému comme nous tous ici et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a envie de on a envie
de td on a envie tu te que tu retrouvé
une vie normale
tu as une tête à une formation de
chocques une formation mais tu as envie
de bosser mais je suis quelqu'un de
l'ambitieux de respectueux de sociable
de dawn est de deux courageuses et le
seul défaut que je pourrais dire c'est
d'être impatient ça c'est pas c'est pas
très grave un peu importe à défaut
quelques fonds castagnos ils étaient
impatients ils se mariaient toujours des
deux premiers jours avec les femmes
alors qu'ils reconnaissent et non pas tu
vois là mais j'ai vraiment envie de t&d
moualek et on va essayer de faire
quelque chose pour toi ça c'est voilà
c'est pas parce que vraiment je suis
touché par son témoignage touché par ta
personnalité est vraiment vous voyez
comme quoi son histoire allait aller
elle est incroyable mais cela peut
arriver à tout le monde et s'est
déclenchée comme ça c'est ça décrocher
et au moment tu te retrouves à 19 ans
sans domicile fixe
en plus on y a on va reparler de cette
histoire de masque parce que c'est vrai
que j'ai dérivé là dessus mais c'est
parce que quand je t'ai vu j'avais envie
de connaître ton histoire c'était pas
prévu
il s'est fait verbaliser cette fois pour
non port du masque ce qui fait ça fait
combien ça fait 6 145 645 euros
bien sûr tu peux pas les payer mais en
fait je ne peux pas les payer déjà ça
c'est sûr et certain
mais il ya rémi gaillard qui a fait la
main exceptionnelle remic j'aime
vraiment fort et micky qui vient en aide
annuelle qui a fait la manche a devant
la mairie pour récolter une somme de 145
euros pour payer mes amendes mais manque
de pot pour moi
j'ai perdu en dix ans n'a pas reçu une
désarmante qui a été majoré du coût il
nous reste deux amendes à payer mais la
somme d'argent a été récolté pour payer
les amendes mais les deux amants dont on
va s'en occuper aussi je te le dis voilà
arrête de tendons goisses avec ça et
j'aurais remercie rémi gaillard qui est
un garçon exceptionnel vraiment qui
encore bouger dit bouge acte énormément
voilà que ce soit pour la cause animale
ce soit pour la cause d'alex et rémy je
sais pas si l'on regarde ce soir mais
bravo à lui et c'est parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui parle mais rémy il fait
voilà et il avance et y bouge
alex alors c'est incroyable quand même
cette histoire il fait il sait
verbaliser tu peux un t'as pas de masque
pour tu sortais dans la rue sans masque
en fait je vous dire la vérité nous
simplement la première le jour même où
je suis arrivé sur montpellier c'est
vraiment le jour même dans le quart
d'heure suivant j'ai voulu faire la
manche a devant le monoprix et je
n'avais pas le masque d'accord et ça a
été ma première verbalisation et la
police municipale de montpellier m'a
clairement de j mais ce gain à l'ex
monsieur guy alexandre où je vais vous
en plus carrément les mots qui m'ont dit
vous allez les gars vous allez dès que
vous allez dégagez de montpellier parce
que déjà d'une on en veut le nouveau
maire monsieur de la fosse ne veut plus
des sdf dans le centre ville et en plus
de ça vous allait être verbalisé pour le
port du masque et ça ça a été le début
de l'enfer concrètement ça c'est
incroyable oui gilles verdez en fait
c'est presque du harcèlement c'est à
dire que ça va au delà de vous n'avez
pas masquer c'est exactement ça c'est la
politique municipale d'ailleurs que
dénonce rémi gaillard sait on veut plus
de vous dans le centre
donc on trouve tous les moyens pour
faire déguerpir pv après pv majoré mais
monsieur il n'a pas d'adressé fixe donc
le prix majoré il arrive de nulle part
c'est absurde c'est totalement absurde
c'est fou et j'ai oublié de vous dire
aussi je suis convoqué au tribunal la
vendredi le à 10h30 au tribunal de
montpellier au tribunal de justice de
montpellier pour le non port du masque
non si je vous confirme que ma
convocation n'est pas très loin c'est
incroyable vous avez droit à un avocat
bien sûr j'ai lentement j'ai le droit à
un avocat ça que ça a été fait l'église
est parti aujourd'hui je plaide et tout
ça sans problème comme c'est hallucinant
parce que on parle souvent de ceux qui
qui boit qui enfreignent la loi parce
qu'il ya un confinement et dans ce cas
précis repoussée
un exemple mais je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont comme vous on
peut pas laisser faire ça c'est
nettement ses impôts c'est en plus c'est
incroyable ça n'a pas de sens on va pas
aller me mettre un pv quelqu'un qui peut
pas d'elle acheter un masque
qu'est ce qui est à l'essai chez
ramasser c'est absurde et pour le coup
une ville doit en premier lieu protégé
ceux qui sont là qui sont mal un jeu
complètement je trouve ça absolument
dingue mon baptême et heures parler de
ce qui m'a qui font les d'udine xterra
ça paraît bien dérisoire mais dans votre
cas vous et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens moi ça ccc à cc abominable pas
ce que c'est c'est de l'acharnement il a
raison je vois la maladie sont ceux
qu'on s'acharne bon et demain sur avril
il va avoir un rendez vous avec un
monsieur qui nous happe et qui s'appelle
franck belhache travaille dans une boîte
qui s'appelle rico qui vend des et des
photocopieurs etc qui forment plein de
commerciaux et qui va qui vont se
rencontrer pour te former voilà j'en
avoir l'info donc si dot a rien à faire
si tu peux aller le voir rien à faire
là-bas magnifique juste normal moi
j'étais censé prendre montera à 10h30
vraiment en prendre un autre train d'en
prendre un autre c'est pas très grave
donc demain tu vas aller le rencontrer
il a été touché par par ton témoignage
et voilà donc comme quoi ça peut bouger
cette je vais te faire bosser le
l'entretien moi j'en ai jamais fait de
ma vie des autres
tu t'adresses à la mauvaise personne moi
je sais je suis nul en effet un parce
que moi aussi je voulais faire je
voulais vendre des photocopieurs un jour
le mec j'ai été recommandé par quelqu'un
il a appelé mais qu'après il m'a dit
c'est qui ce guignol que tu me voyais
donc j'espère j'espère que tu feras pas
comme moi mon avec st
non mais vraiment et y est on est on est
vraiment touché par part importante au
ton histoire et on va voir bien sûr je
vais voir le sondage mais j'y vois la
wicca 15% non 85 95 % de gens qui disent
oui mais c'est vrai que j'ai du mal à le
comprendre ça oui alex ça fait plaisir
d'entendre que les 80 85 % de personnes
qui disent que c'est pas normal de
verbaliser les sdf mais je comprends pas
où sont les 15% qui disent oui parce que
l'on fait
j'aime j'aime pas les mots alors ici y
avait qu un oui à la basse et xsara au
départ oui parce que y ait des
établissements comme les restos du coeur
ou les services sociaux donnent des
masques gratuitement ce gens qui en ont
besoin
et puis après j'ai effectivement lu
votre histoire je me dis mais c'est pas
possible c'est exactement ce qu'a dit
cyril c'est un gars c'est pas on peut
pas on ne peut pas mettre ça sur une
histoire de port de masques en plus il
paraît que vous l'aviez sur vous un juge
mais que vous n'avez pas mis d'assez
objets légers les photos de moi en étant
contrôlé par la police où j'avais le
masque et ils m'ont verbaliser quand
même et pour en revenir à ce que vous
avez dit qui est des aspects des cas
quand même des associations qui donnent
des masques c'est vrai il y à quelques
associations qui donnent des masques
mais il nous en donnent que 1 ou 2 4 je
te le dis alors on a plein de
propositions de travail je te le dis à
mon avis la tétée au bon bah écoute tu
as trop de taf qui est également le
président de planet sushi qui m'envoie
un message qui me dit si on peut aider
n'hésite pas voilà donc je te donne il
va t'appeler également voilà donc je
pense que ce qu'on va essayer de trouver
quelque chose
très vite voilà franck bellaïche un
poste de commercial chez ricoh voilà
donc la tchaux et n'arrête pas et il ya
ma mère qui demande voilà que tu restes
avec moi tout le temps que merci alex en
tout cas pourtant témoignages j'espère
que ça va bouger très vite je donnerai
des nouvelles dès demain et bien sûr aux
téléspectateurs pour leur dire comment
ça s'est passé
tu vas rencontrer le patron de sushis le
patron de cette société enfin voilà des
directeurs de cette société ricoh qui
sherley les commerciaux et qui forme des
commerciaux qui est décidée peut-être de
te former et on va voir comment ça s'est
passé pour toi mais on va suivre ton
aventure et tu vois peut-être que
c'était un mal pour un bien
ils les inventent bien entendu on s'en
occupe on va régler tout ça et bravo
encore à gré me gaillard que j'aime
beaucoup
oui mon allait placer un dernier mot
j'aimerais poser une question à mon cher
et tendre maire monsieur de la fosse
mais pourquoi ils la maire de
montpellier oui pourquoi il organise
cette traque des sdf et pourquoi il
donne les ordres à la police municipale
et nationale de verbaliser les sdf et de
les faire éloignés du centre où je te
dis on va essayer de le contacter il
demain également poursuit viennent
peut-être sur cette zac de moi une
question qu'on est un fake style avec
lui pour qu'il s'explique la thune et
qui nous disent ce qui se passe merci
alex est un ce roadster